tens of thousands of coloradans are
waiting for the smoke to clear to learn
what they've lost things look okay from
up here but there is some smoldering in
the area so until you really get down
there it's almost impossible to know
david marks who lives in fire ravaged
boulder county knows three people who've
lost their homes
full homes engulfed in flames so 50 60
feet high probably
it was really i've never seen anything
like it i mean just house after house
fences just stuff flying through the air
just caught on fire
authorities say they believe as many as
500 homes have probably been destroyed
as the fire tore through
drought-stricken neighborhoods at least
one first responder and several other
people were injured as winds of up to
169 kilometers per hour spread intense
flames with terrifying speed
colorado governor jared polis and
boulder county sheriff joe pelley toured
the devastation from the air this was a
disaster in fast motion
all over the course of half a day nearly
all the damage many families having
minutes
minutes to get whatever they could their
pets their kids into the car
and leave
last 24 hours have been devastating
polis says president joe biden promised
to free up federal funds with an
expedited declaration of a major
disaster john hendren al jazeera